so now I might go and Pierce Morgan
we'll see all I'm going to say they're
going to put me on with some women
presenters to talk about if women should
be commentating on men's sports and my
first point is my credentials I have
played volleyball basketball I ran track
and I played soccer you guys call it
football in high school Paul I can see
you uh rolling your eyes there you
clearly don't agree well I keep seeing
women given special handouts and special
treatment I'm seeing the same thing that
he's seeing but some of the women who
are getting these jobs are the best
women I mean I looked at I've looked at
their Instagrams they look like
influencers